welcome to this video this is I am
ceduna playing me say doona okey-dokey
let's see Wow the Alvin's count again
whatever those gambits well you know
it's not good but you don't really check
it here okay this is one of the better
lines but recently screw one game up
there I remember ok so the ship here
first
I can't do this I don't know well
actually g4 simply antiquing the pawn
down hmm it also should be okay
something like h5 seems to be in order
g5 what okay g5 so
well Kim now I probably wins with a
couple of continuations against that
looks oh so weird 94 496 or g4 494 ok
let's do that I don't believe in this
one bit there g5
where is he going in the first place age
60 well
okay I really don't know where is he
going even to h4 maybe hmm ok I'm taking
him
so what is this point is there's some
kind of point to it 25 might be might be
something okay if I just go here
throughout the night f6 and what does
this means then I mean what is this a
chief I've it it's early in the day he
can't be drunk it's not hit under normal
circumstances okay yeah knight Knight to
f5 right oh and it's gone native five
yeah can you do it every does it really
have something else than taking don't
see it really just have the same with
chick I wonder if Bishop g5 is something
Bishop t5 shop g 2 nite c 4
and I don't want to spend too much time
here if you if you do you might be
regretting it later so H for Quincy 195
all looks good maybe Quincy one down is
maybe 55 is still possible okay let's
take that Bishop g5 root g one
I don't know if it's up with this if
this was the best continuation don't
really know that but it's definitely not
a bad one
so yeah Quincy 193 might still be
someone that's not true key I can do I
cannot take safar okay that's not
possible then maybe just age for him and
maybe age 40 I am closing the g file not
sure that is such a great idea
okay two minutes two minutes I wonder if
maybe roaches seven this is an idea at
some point that takes pawn takes was
checking takes e6 check just opening up
the whole thing
hmm
can add some more coke quickly go to as
king at all I don't see it here maybe
still this okay if it takes Quincy for
something I've Quincy three which is
also causing some problems
great I don't know Bishop there I can
have to have to move after move quicker
check I'm not sure this was the best
solution really but at some point you
just have to make moves okay i'm at
least I'm a little bit ahead on the
clock even
Bishop d3 is interesting but I can take
on g6 check something on d1 would be
made but I also have some checks iam
yeah like 27 for Queen D one mate but I
have queen age three check it's a big
problem so okay I can't read queens now
I can't write any queencess easy come on
let's do this time morning ok so let the
nut not pothole into some stupid media
that's just just for one moment think
about it check yeah that's all came
check here I have tons of porn Sam
and pawns your other problem okay 96
second cheek so I'm going back let's
let's prepare that properly set not
winning I cannot believe this stuff okay
sis it's very low and check check black
for fits on time Wow jim was really
really weird him that what what he came
I g5 is like what cities it's maybe the
I don't know I don't know what that is
but it's completely bonkers I mean black
is black as much worth anyway maybe it's
kind of ok what the heck but well this
is the opening here and p it just does
not get to keep their part in the long
run but i thought like each five or
something or Bishop e7 man this this is
a very strange move so G for night each
form an ID for okay that that's in fact
engine engine moves and it will just win
a queen f4 is even stronger Bishop g5
you for hmm yeah that's that's much
better even and he just loses a piece
but that's not bad I mean what kind of a
position is that GX f six work g one is
better okay
yeah it's it's just really winning maybe
I should have traded Queens em that's
its that's easier okay at least that the
camp is always giving me plus three so i
can take c7 here why didn't that do that
but okay and the Queen takes a five was
also possible yeah well I saw her the
HEPA death or valid straight Queens
that's easy but I did not see I did not
see night a three this is sister this is
a nice trick down and makes things
really tricky check now I have to be
precise which I wasn't III is better and
winning but and charlie this looks kind
of strange to allow that but the pants
now are too strong in wide winds that
would have won but here it gets
surprisingly surprisingly problematic
yeah here f five wins I did this however
it plays great moves now I place all the
engine moves with nothing on the clock
so that's great look T for Jane how it
gets completely unclear and well at this
moment I noticed that I'm also town with
the clock wow what do we had game thanks
for watching